and I'm tired today.
A good workout.
Here's
what we're going to do.
Uh,
we're going to go.
Oops.
Okay, we're going to go get the other
container,
And I'm going to just chill here for a
little bit and we're going to do a
little bit on the client end. We're
going to see if I can figure that out
and then maybe I'll start just some
basic experiments on Puffer 4.
I got all day tomorrow for Puffer 4.
Holy tired.
That's what happens when you do twohour
exercise.
put something on in the background here.
I'll answer whatever questions. Other
than that, just going to chill and do
some client dev, which happens to be
open source, so it's a stream.
Uh let's go look at
Hey, Joseph. Why does it seem like ML
researchers are bullish on RL versus uh
so they're not actually I'd say it's the
opposite where pretty much zero people
are doing RL right now like real RL the
language model [ __ ] does not count that
is stupid baby mode RL for babies um
to give you an idea of the difference
they are training near one trillion
parameter models
with tiny amounts of data. We are
training with more data than they have
on their 100,000 GPUs on one GPU. But we
are training tiny models.
You know,
it takes them more than a second on all
their GPUs to get a forward pass.
It takes us,
I don't know, a few micro seconds.
Very, very different scales.
Now, why I personally
the researchers I know of are Yeah, but
it's LMR RL, right?
So, why I personally am super interested
in RL is because it pairs incredibly
well with fast simulation. Uh,
everybody's just straight up trolled on
the engineering side. So, we can make it
10,000 times faster than anybody's ever
seen. And in fact, we have in Puffer 4.
And there's essentially no other way
that you're going to solve fiddly,
unintuitive optimization problems. And a
lot of problems out there are fiddly,
unintuitive optimization problems. You
will never solve them with language
models.
There you go. Hey, Liberty. We're just
going to hang out and do some client dev
on um this compute marketplace
simulator. I'm adding a little test to
this and uh we're going to fix some
bugs. So, I figure I stream a little
client work because I can because this
one's open source. And then if I've got
any energy after that, uh we will do
some experiments on Puffer 4.
trading. Not quite. This is a compute
marketplace.
We do have stuff in finance that is not
open source.
This specific client decided to open
source this end, which means there's no
reason I can't stream it.
You can go check their stuff out at
archive.
Okay. So, why is this recognizing
this is recognizing revenue? Super
weird.
Is this Let's just make sure this is not
like a off by one, off by two.
Okay, this is not
very odd.
accepting job
and the best response price.
[snorts]
Still interesting stuff.
Yeah.
I mean there's a market in Neural MMO
like that and end has a full market if
you want to play around.
How much compute do you need for neural
MMO?
Well, you can do decently on 1590.
Our biggest runs are 6490s.
It'll be faster in puff four as well, of
course.
Trying to think what I will have to look
at to fix this
bug.
Recognizing revenue.
This is so weird.
Oh, I see it's at the bottom.
Interesting.
So, it's not filling any orders. That
would be why.
Oops.
Uh, my charm just froze.
scripted buy price. No, we need scripted
sell price.
Not scripted. Damn it.
Why is it not
making any trades? Yes.
Holy.
Well, that's not the right price.
Well, there's a request price actually.
That's weird.
Very weird.
Okay, there are some reasonable
requests.
Let's see why their response sucks.
RL and Mat Lab.
Yeah.
Way easier to just chuck us a contract
at that point.
basically will cost you less than
somebody's salary to get a pretty solid
prototype.
Less than half of a decent person's
salary even.
That'll go up as puffer gets uh bigger
though.
figure out what the hell is wrong with
That's
can accept the request
for 105 nodes
recognizing a bunch of revenue, right?
Does that look reasonable?
I'm quite confused then. This actually
seems fine to me.
Oo.
Oh, okay. Look.
Recognizing revenue. Recognizing
revenue. Right.
That's like a good amount of revenue.
And then it got one more here.
Okay. So now here we have the uh revenue
recognition problem
because I kind of messed with how we
recognize revenue.
I think I can solve this problem today,
right?
Uh
I got to think about this for a second,
though.
Gac
got the Keen shirt.
So the issue, let me explain the problem
here. Um, right now we have the agents
recognizing
the sale of the compute
as soon as it is sold. So like if you
have a job that's going to be 100 days
or whatever, 100 hours, we recognize all
the revenue as soon as you make that
sale.
That makes it pretty difficult to come
up with a reasonable
estimate.
I just have to think about it a little
bit though. It shouldn't be hard.
Let me just figure out how I want to do
this.
Brain is not braining.
You want to optimize. So the agent
should be incentivized to always make
the sales.
How's reserve pricing work? Do you pay
over time or do you pay it up front?
Does it matter? For our case,
I should probably just at the end I
should subtract outstanding jobs, right?
It's kind of annoying to do it that way,
but let's see if I can do it.
So,
Because what do we do here?
This is a bad estimate. Yes, it is.
Seller expense.
Let's take this out
and we'll put seller expense into
Wait, I literally already have it here.
What the hell am I doing then?
Revenue recognized up front.
We just do update jobs, right?
That was double counting energy expense.
Gross.
That's bad.
Don't do that.
So if the agent is curistic,
we continue.
Let's just do
cancel.
Can I not just do this up front? Wait, I
can do this up front and not screw
myself.
buyer expense. So what I I basically
what I need to do is there's one
estimate for the reward
and then there's one estimate that
discounts
the actual episode length.
So then we have
quest duration
used
devices
agent from
terminal.
Does it
does that actually prevent it?
No, it doesn't. I'm screwing myself,
aren't I?
flipped duration
and then this is going to be
duration.
Yeah.
job revenue,
duration.
this is times duration.
Good.
I think that's good.
Energy expense.
This is not getting logged fully
correctly,
but that's actually decently close to
what we expect.
Here's the restroom real quick and then
we will continue.
kind of weird Weird how I have it, isn't
it?
With this like job expense, energy
expense.
That's
right.
>> Revenue
profit.
Good.
Now we can try to load some more
reasonable settings in.
That does not make any sense to me at
all.
Okay.
Let me just um real quick,
how about we just do four
Way less profit.
Let's see how it would make that big of
a difference.
Allocated within 10 ticks
and reasonable price. Yeah. So, I'm
calcing this wrong.
Important.
If I had to guess, it would be right
here, right
in the uh this revenue recognition
sub duration.
What about the tick?
Are we advancing the tick correctly?
Thank you.
in Ocean on the repo. Yes, everything on
Ocean is on the repo. Play with it some
to set it up for hardware. Yeah, so
everything that's on the website on
Ocean is in the repo.
This here is a client project which is
open source but not in ocean. It's not
on the website.
One, two, three, four, five, six. Wait.
One.
That doesn't seem correct to me.
Sellers back.
SpaceX acquired XAI.
Did that go through?
Was it XAI acquiring?
Is it XAI acquiring SpaceX or SpaceX
acquiring XAI?
I bet you it's the terabytes.
Yeah, I bet you it's the TV usage.
usage.
It's going to be one
Yep. So, it's just um
job duration
DR
zero.
nice
and then if I literally just put this to
um
drop notes it's going to be all 200
and you get the expected outcome here
of having one request.
and then let's say that you have uh if
instead you just have one request coming
in
Now, what do I do about this? There's
not much to learn here.
It's a sanity check for sure.
I mean, we should probably sanity check
it.
80% and 65k or reaching 131. I don't
know. I think 131 is actually the
theoretical max though, right? Like
you're out of tiles to even merge all
the stuff you need to merge, right?
Not reason
yet.
I don't trust Alman as far as I can
throw him.
This is a pathological liar.
I think Alman's lying and knows it.
Daario is sincere but nuts.
Um,
Elon's doing what he's can. He's just
kind of goofy and doesn't really know
the space.
And Demis is an actual genius. So,
funny enough, it ends up deep mine top
of list. Now,
how far could you throw Sam Alman? I
don't know.
We could go test uh
like a 100 pound sandbag or something.
Andrew interview his most spot. I
haven't seen that.
I spent a little bit of time in this
lab. Fun fact.
I didn't talk to him once though. I
talked to his PhD students.
I missed the one lunch that he went to
actually to see um his like undergrad
researchers. So, I missed that one lunch
because I'd been up um coding on the uh
the research project I was on until like
3:00 or 4 in the morning and then I just
like crashed and he sent the invite that
morning.
Come on. Let's get this config and just
be done.
So, I wouldn't bet on it.
I don't think who's there that I know
who's cool.
I don't think I really know anybody.
A couple people at Stanford
at all.
HD know a few there.
Stanford is nice. I still think it's the
best place to do undergrad.
I mean, the difference is like
at least it's nice there. And yeah, a
lot of There are a lot of just really
stupid people. But then you can go to
MIT and like the smart people don't
leave their room anyways and are
completely autistic and cannot speak in
complete sentences or maintain eye
contact. So
I guess there's also Keltech. Keltech is
pretty freaking cool.
Uh yeah, that's just [ __ ] hit piece,
dude.
Yeah, that's [ __ ] hit piece.
How can people be bad bad communicators
and still be smart?
A lot of people at MIT, you put a math
problem two inches in front of their
nose that nobody else can solve, they
will solve it. you ask them to present
anything or speak in complete sentences
or even think about something like
higher level as to the position of their
work and like whether they're solving
the right problem or not. Uh-uh.
How so? Uh because Jake, the vast
majority of those accommodations are
just like time on tests.
And
if you're writing tests, if you're like
overly constraining the time on tests
anyways, like your course is [ __ ]
It's like actually not significant
at all.
Yeah, they call it that. I don't know.
I've I've gone through that whole thing,
Jake. That whole like that there are a
bunch of dumb things with Stanford. That
ain't one of them.
Got any MIT people working with you on
Puffer? Uh, one lab I did a couple
things with. Our biggest collab right
now is NYU
with the driveins.
Yeah, because like that's literally all
it is. It's not like they give you
easier questions or anything, right?
And the requirement for that is also
it's basically just that you demonstrate
that you do better on uh on standardized
tests if you're given more time. So it's
like
it's kind of no big deal.
Like I technically had one of those as
well um for undergrad and I had one for
grad school but I stopped using it
because people in grad school they just
they stopped writing stupid tests
you know at some point
it's basically past the intro classes.
Um the professors get smarter and they
stop like trying to cram way too many
questions into two hours.
It's very difficult because the
universities they can only figure out
how like to test if you can like do x
easy thing in short y amount of time.
The thing that actually matters in the
real world is like can you not waste six
months solving the wrong problem or
using the completely wrong approach on
the right problem.
Right?
It depends. Some well some of the upper
div like the grad courses there are
professors who will write an exam that
has between two and four questions for
four hours.
I remember there was one professor I had
I think it was like a six question exam
or an eight question exam. You had 24
hours and it was expected to take you
the full 24 hours. Like get a bunch of
sleep because you're going to be doing
this for the next day straight.
like the thing is Stanford does have a
couple very good professors
that just teach hard ass courses.
Okay. Why What am I doing here? I'm like
spacing out.
Uh I got to solve this before dinner.
That's not good.
Okay.
Uh okay. So there is a problem with the
reporting here.
Ah, come on.
What am I screwing up here?
Let's go double check if I have like No,
episode length of 100 is correct as
well.
It's action is zero and four, right? Is
what it's supposed to be.
Yes,
we have the episode 9.
Am I doing anything else stupid?
Don't think so.
First tick on the first reset.
I'll just double check this. I don't
think it's this.
one of the Dota team guys also retweeted
that saying that it's like It could be,
but it's probably just that um IA was
pissed off he wasn't getting enough GPUs
for his research.
Oh, you [ __ ]
You absolute burger.
there we go.
Yay.
Not being a burger.
And then if we want to do U reward
scale. We'll do negative. Let's see.
This should not work.
Perfect. It optimizes
not making money.
All right. Good.
I'm pleased with this test.
Is that a real company problem? It can
be
in OpenAI's case. Absolutely.
I mean, I think arguably the person in
the world who is most responsible for RL
not having gotten to where it should
have been is Sam Alman.
Um
I don't know officially what the
discussion was around Dota and why that
research didn't continue.
Uh but ultimately the responsibility for
like continuing or discontinuing
projects would be on him. And OpenAI
would have absolutely shredded RL if
they just continued on with the Dota
line of work with that team. And instead
they rolled everything up into LLM's
research and they basically doomed the
field. like DeepMind tried a couple of
things, but then after that, after 2019,
that's pretty much what doomed RL for
the next like six years.
Like, I honestly believe if I weren't
doing this with Puffer, it just wouldn't
get done. Like, maybe in a decade we
rediscover RL again and we wasted a
decade and now nobody even remembers the
things that matter. like huge huge
amount of setback
robotics research. Yeah, same thing.
They also doomed the robotics research,
right? So, arguably I think it's like
squarely like the full consolidation all
in on LM that did so much damage to AI.
I think we're going to ultimately look
back thinking that they did um that that
single thing did more damage to AI as a
whole than um you know advancing
language modeling by a couple years did.
And it would have been a different story
if um open I had discovered Transformers
but they didn't.
I have nothing bad to say about Radford,
though. Radford's awesome.
Nobody has anything bad to say about Red
P ever. Red P is awesome.
Ilia, man. I didn't get to spend enough
time with Ilia, but like
He is the only person I think I've ever
met who I actually just envy the way he
is able to think and communicate.
I mean he really more than anybody has
the ability to just slow down
and make things clear
and make himself heard and understood
with no bluster and no [ __ ]
I mean, he has the research to back it
obviously, too. I wouldn't just go based
on that.
I don't know. He's just he has a very
rare gift.
Okay, that's nice.
and commit this.
Okay, let me uh message this guy real
quick.
Yeah, open was very cool. Honestly,
turtle, I'm like I am not a genius by
any means whatsoever. I'm really not.
I have a couple things I'm very good at
that give me um that I'm very good at
like positioning stuff and finding
angles that people have not thought
about and then seeing stuff very clearly
in that way. That's pretty much what
Puffer is.
Like if you put me in front of any like
common fix problem, I mean I'll do okay
on a lot of stuff but nothing remotely
impressive.
Doesn't matter though ultimately. What
matters is if you can actually like the
true test ultimately is whether or not
you can make something that moves the
needle, improves the world.
Anyways, I got to run for dinner. Um,
so I streamed delivery of one milestone
or not milestone, one one update. Let's
say this is not a full milestone's worth
of work. This is like one small chunk of
it. Uh, no crypto crap 24. Screw that.
Uh,
I think we're going to see how I feel
after dinner. If I have energy, I might
stream a little bit of work on Puffer.
If not, I'm just going to chill. And
then tomorrow is all day all day stream
on puffer dev
same amount of environment and twerk
most people unfortunately not calamaria
there's c there's a certain amount that
is innate I've unfortunately I know like
I not too many of them I know a handful
of people who worked really really hard
and just don't have what it takes
mentally
um now I will say that you don't have to
be a total genius
You don't have to be a total genius.
What do I do for chilling? Just going to
play some Runescape likely. I've been
enjoying that game lately. But yeah, I
got to go. I'm We'll see if I'm back
later. I'll be on all day tomorrow.
We're going to probably crank some
experiments on Puffer 4. We're going to
clean some stuff up. Going to get more
things working. It'll be good.
All right. I've got uh Yeah, I'm going
to have dinner. See you all around. Star
Puffer Love on GitHub, please.